SENTENCING FOR MIKE FLYNN BEING
PUSHED BACK UNTIL MARCH, AFTER A
DRAMATIC DAY IN COURT.
THE FEDERAL JUDGE SAYING HE WAS
DISGUSTED WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
FOR LYING TO THE FBI AND WARNED
THAT HE COULD BE SENT TO PRISON.
THE JUDGE ALSO SPARKING A MEDIA
FIRESTORM AFTER QUESTIONING
WHETHER FLYNN COMMITTED TREASON
BEFORE WALKING BACK HIS
COMMENTS.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS REACTING
TODAY AND IT IS STANDING BY ITS
CRITICISM OF THE CASE AND ALSO
BLASTING JAMES COMEY.
>> WHAT WE DO KNOW THAT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE, SELF-ADMITTED OF
JAMES COMEY, IS THAT THE FBI
BROKE STANDARD PROTOCOL IN THE
WAY THAT THEY CAME IN AND
AMBUSHED GENERAL FLYNN AND IN
THE WAY THAT THEY QUESTIONED HIM
AND IN THE WAY THAT THEY
ENCOURAGED HIM NOT TO HAVE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE
PRESENT.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE JAMES COMEY
TOLD US THAT, AND HE SAID THAT
THE VERY REASON THEY DID IT WAS
BECAUSE THE ONLY REASON THEY DID
IT, IT WAS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THEY THOUGHT
THEY COULD GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, DANA, THE
JUDGE MAKING A LOT OF HEADLINES.
JUDGE EMMET SULLIVAN HAS A VERY
GOOD REPUTATION.
BUT HE SAID THE TREASON THING
THEN HE WALKED IT BACK.
THEN HE SAID YOU WERE WORKING
FOR A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT WHILE
YOU ARE WORKING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, TALKING ABOUT
TURKEY.
THEN HE GOT THE DATES WRONG AND
HAD TO CORRECT IT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DAYS EVENTS?
>> Dana: IT'S GOOD TO REMEMBER
THAT JUDGES HAVE THIS DISCRETION
IN POWER AND IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO YOU
PUT ON THE BENCH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FOCUS FROM DAY
ONE HAS BEEN TRYING TO GET AS
MANY JUDGES CONFIRMED AS
POSSIBLE, AND THE SENATE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO FULFILL THAT.
EMMET SULLIVAN IS KNOWN TO
SOMEBODY, HE GETS A LOT OF CASES
THROUGH HIS COURT.
HE'S NOT SHY ABOUT GETTING PRESS
ATTENTION.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, I GUESS
MONDAY, HE WENT FROM HERO TO
ZERO IN A WEEK.
HE HAD ASKED, I WANT TO MORE
ABOUT THE SITUATION.
IF YOU CAME HERE AND YOU PLED
GUILTY BUT YOU ARE SAYING NOW
THAT THE FBI AGENTS TRICKED YOU.
I NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT
AND I WANT EVERYONE TO DELIVER
THE DOCUMENTS TO ME.
FOR A WEEK, WE SPENT IT THINKING
THE JUDGE IS GOING TO THROW THE
CASE OUT BECAUSE OF THIS THING,
THE FIRST THING HE ASKED TWO
DAYS DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE YOUR
PLEA?
NO.
I THINK IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION, THAT WORKS A LITTLE
BIT.
FLYNN'S LAWYERS DID AN EXCELLENT
JOB OF GETTING HIM TO WHERE HE
IS WHERE HE WAS GOING TO GET NO
JAIL TIME.
WITH THE JUDGE, THEY HAVE
DISCRETION.
SENTENCING GUIDELINES ONLY THAT.
THEY ARE GUIDELINES.
THE JUDGE IS BASICALLY
INDICATING HE WAS POSSIBLY GOING
TO GET JAIL TIME TODAY.
FLYNN'S TEAM ASKED FOR A RECESS.
THEY GO BACK AND THEY'RE GOING
TO DELAY IT NOW FOR THREE
MONTHS.
>> Jesse: IF YOU ARE LOOKING
AT NO JAIL TIME, I WOULDN'T
START WITH ANYTHING THAT COULD
LOCK YOU UP EVEN FOR A DAY.
I WOULD NOT DO WELL IN PRISON,
GREG, EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
>> Greg: AS LONG AS YOU DON'T
FLIRT.
>> Jesse: ONLY YOU WOULD DO
WORSE THAN I WOULD DO.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
TODAY WAS LIKE WHEN YOU'RE ON
THE TARMAC OF A DELAYED FLIGHT
AND THE GUY COMES ON AND SAYS
NOW WE ARE GOING BACK TO THE
GATE.
OH, WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE
A COUPLE THOUGHTS.
THE JUDGE SEEMED VERY DISGUSTED
WITH FLYNN.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE FLYNN
DIDN'T GIVE THE JUDGE WHAT THEY
WANT -- WHAT HE WANTED.
THEY DIDN'T GET EVERYTHING THEY
NEEDED.
THE JUDGE WANTED A PLAYSTATION
FOR CHRISTMAS BUT HE GOT A
JUMPING ROPE.
THAT'S HOW I GOT FROM THAT.
BUT I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
QUESTION THAT I ASKED THAT
PEOPLE HATE, IS THIS NEWS?
IT'S A NEWS HANGOVER.
THIS IS THE LINGERING HEADACHE
AND NAUSEA FROM 2016 THAT WON'T
GO AWAY.
SO THE MEDIA HERE AND ELSEWHERE,
IT FEELS REALLY DRAMATIC.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT, BUT IT'S
NOT.
IT'S NOT.
THIS IS JUST THE ONLY GAME IN
TOWN RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT'S THE
HOLIDAYS AND BECAUSE UNDER
TRUMP, THE COUNTRY IS ROLLING
ALONG PRETTY WELL.
TRY TO IGNORE THE STOCK MARKET
BECAUSE IT'S THE END OF THE
YEAR.
THAT TENDS TO HAPPEN.
THINGS ARE GOING ALONG.
WE HAVE DECLINES IN CRIME,
TERROR.
OPTIMISM IS HIGH.
THE MEDIA NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THIS
THING, THIS COMEY, FLYNN,
COLLISION.
IT'S LIKE A TRIANGLE OF IDIOCY.
BY THE WAY, I DO BELIEVE IT OR
IF ANYTHING HAPPENS YOU WILL GET
PARDONED.
I THINK HE DESERVES A PARDON.
IF YOU COMPARED TO PREVIOUS
PARDONS, THIS IS NOTHING
COMPARED TO THE PEOPLE CLINTON
PARDON.
CLINTON PARDON HOW MANY PEOPLE
ON THE LAST DAY?
16 TERRORISTS.
16 PEOPLE WHO TRIED TO BOMB OUR
COUNTRY OR DID BOMB OUR COUNTRY.
IF YOU SAFELY FLYNN DOESN'T
DESERVE A PARDON, READ YOUR
HISTORY.
>> Jesse: I THINK I KNOW WHAT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
SAID THE JUDGE WAS LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING.
THEY'VE BEEN SENDING UP SMOKE
SIGNALS THAT MAYBE HE WAS GOING
TO PULL THE PLEA.
THEY BECOME UNTIL THE JUDGE I
WAS SET UP.
I DIDN'T REALLY LIVE.
THE JUDGE WAS KIND OF ASKING ARE
YOU REALLY GOING TO GO THAT FAR.
THE MINUTE MUELLER'S TEAM HEARD
THAT WAS A POSSIBILITY, THEY
JUST DANGLED THAT TURKEY
CONSULTING THING THAT HE WAS HE
WAS UNREGISTERED AS A FOREIGN
AGENT.
THEY ARE GOING TO HIT HIM HARD
IF HE DOESN'T DO WHAT THEY
AGREED TO DO.
>> Jedidiah: THIS WHOLE STORY
BECOME SO CONFUSING BECAUSE HE
CAN'T RECONCILE IT.
I CAN'T RECONCILE WHY HE LIED.
AS SOMEONE WHO WAS THE INCOMING
NATIONAL SECURITY PERSON, YOU
WOULD EXPECT THEM TO HAVE SOME
CONTACT WITH RUSSIAN
AMBASSADORS.
WHY WOULD HE LIVE?
THEN YOU LOOK AT WHY WOULD YOU
BE ADVISED NOT TO HAVE LAWYERS
PRESENT.
IF THAT'S NOT SHADY, IT
CERTAINLY LOOKS SHADY.
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE FACT THAT
THE AGENTS KNEW ESSENTIALLY WHAT
HE HAD SAID TO THE RUSSIAN
INVESTOR.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING THERE AND
INTERVIEWING HIM FOR?
YOU ALREADY KNOW.
ARE YOU LOOKING TO ENTRAP HIM.
THEN YOU HAVE THE 302, THE FBI
DOCUMENT ABOUT THE REPORT FILED
NINE MONTHS LATER AFTER THE
INCIDENT.
SO SONY THINGS ABOUT, THE REASON
I THINK IT'S GOING TO ULTIMATELY
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO B
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO E
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO A
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO P
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO R
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO O
EITHER GET -- THERE'S GOING TO .
THERE'S SO MUCH NONSENSE.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE INTERVIEWING
HIM WOUND UP BEING PETER STRZOK,
THE GUY WHO HAS THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES, THE ANTI-TRUMP TEXT
MESSAGES TO HIS LOVER.
THE WHOLE THING IS A DISASTER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO
END BUT YOU CAN LOOK AT THIS AND
SAY FLYNN SHOULDN'T HAVE LIED.
IT WAS ABSURD THAT HE LIED.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO ME THAT HE
DID IN FACT LYING THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
BUT ALSO THE FACT THAT THERE WAS
SOME SORT OF BIZARRE SET UP TO
HAVE HIM HOPEFULLY LIE AND
APPEASE CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT WERE
EXPECTING HIM OR WANTING TO
LIVE.
IT'S REALLY A MESS.
>> Jesse: IT IS A MESS.
JUAN, CLEAN IT UP FOR US.
>> Jedidiah: CLEAN UP WHEN I
JUST SAID.
>> Juan: I WANTED TO CLEAN UP
JESSE'S HAIR.
IF YOU GO TO JAIL AND I COME TO
VISIT, I WILL BRING THE HAIR GE
GEL.
>> Greg: YOU COULD HIDE THINGS
IN HIS HAIR.
YOU COULD HIDE A FILE.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU REALIZE YOU DO NEED A
HAIRCUT.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU, GREG.
>> Juan: IT LOOKS BETTER THAN
STEPHEN MILLER'S HAIR.
>> Greg: THAT IS A LOW BAR.
>> Juan: ANYWAY, I THOUGHT THE
DAY STARTED OFF WITH
DONALD TRUMP WISHING MIGHT FLYNN
GOOD LUCK.
I THOUGHT THAT'S PECULIAR.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
AND THEN HE SAYS LOOK, I THINK
THERE IS NO THAT STRZOK AND PAGE
-- MAY BE DELETED EVIDENCE AND
THEN THE REPORTS HAVE SAID
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I'M THINKING WHAT IS GOING ON.
WHAT'S GOING ON IS THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN THIS HAS BECOME HIGHLY
POLITICIZED.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH MIKE FLYNN
IN A COURT OF LAW.
YOU HAVE A JUDGE WHO IS WELL
RESPECTED, A JUDGE WHO, BY THE
WAY, THROUGHOUT THE CONVICTION
OF SENATOR TED STEVENS, A
REPUBLICAN, ONCE HE FOUND THE
PROSECUTORS HE BELIEVED ENGAGED
IN MISCONDUCT.
THIS IS NOT A JUDGE WHO IS ANY
WEAK WILLOW.
THIS IS A STRONG, COMPETENT
JUDGE, WELL RESPECTED BY BOTH
SIDES.
HERE'S THE THING.
WHEN YOU SAY TO SOMEONE LIKE
MIKE FLYNN, YOU SOLD OUT YOUR
COUNTRY, JESSE, I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYTHING MORE DAMNING
THAN THAT.
THIS COMES FROM A JUDGE WHO AS
YOU SAID GOT THE 302.
>> Jesse: CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY
DID THE JUDGE SAY YOU SOLD OUT
YOUR COUNTRY.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WAS HE
POINTING TO?
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S FRUSTRATING AS THEY
SHOULD HAVE KEPT THE WHOLE THING
UNDER SEAL SO TO NOT GIVE US A
LOOK AT THIS DOCUMENT THAT HAS
THREE QUARTERS OF IT REDACTED.
THE JUDGE HAS READ THE WHOLE
THING UNREDACTED.
WE DON'T GET TO KNOW.
THAT'S WHY --
THAT'S WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
>> Juan: TO WHAT DANA SAID, I
THINK THIS IS KEY IN RESPONSE TO
WHAT GREG SAID ABOUT EVERYONE
WHO GOT PARDONED.
MIKE FLYNN, NOT ONLY WAS HE
ADVISING A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE WHILE ALSO
REPRESENTING A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT, HE WAS GOING TO
CLASSIFIED BRIEFINGS FROM THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT THAT'S GIVEN TO
OUR TOP PRESIDENTIAL CONTENDERS.
THEN ONCE HE BECOMES A NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, YOU CAN'T GET
MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT.
THIS GUY HAD ALSO BEEN HEAD OF
THE NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCY.
BUT NOW HE'S THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, JESSE, AND
WHAT IS HE DOING?
HE'S DOING BUSINESS FOR A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT WITHOUT
REGISTERING.
>> Jesse: I DON'T WANT TO
MINIMIZE IT BUT EVERYBODY IN THE
SWAMP DOESN'T.
SOME RADICAL CLERIC IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
IT'S NOT AS SHADY AS YOU'RE
MAKING IT OUT TO BE.
I'M NOT EXCUSING IT.
IT WAS ILLEGAL BY NOT
REGISTERING BUT LET'S NOT MAKE
ENOUGH TO BE A HUGE SCANDAL.
>> Juan: IT IS.
IT'S SHOCKING.
ASK DANA.
DANA HAS BEEN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
YOU CAN'T BE THE PRESIDENT'S
ADVISOR AND LIE --
>> Jesse: DANA WOULDN'T NEVER
EVEN MAKE A GRAMMATICAL ERROR.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT, THE MEDIA, THEY CAN'T
FIND COLLUSION.
WHAT IS COLLUSION?
RUSSIA MAYBE SPEND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ON ADS TO INFLUENCE
ELECTION.
HAVE YOU SEEN THOSE ADS?
SERIOUS THEY'VE SEEN THEM?
THEY ARE HILARIOUS.
I CAN'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO FUNNY.
WE SPEND MORE MONEY ON OUR
WARDROBE THAN RUSSIA SPENT ON
THE ADS.
DID YOU SEE THE ADS, JUAN?
YOU'VE GOT TO LOOK AT THEM!
>> Juan: THEY DO THINGS LIKE
BLACK LIVES MATTER,
SECOND AMENDMENT ADVOCATES AND
THEY ARE JUST PUSHING PEOPLE TO
BREAK APART --